Our point of intersection is right here. Because this point lies on the line y
equals 19, we already know that its y-coordinate must be 19. Its x-coordinate we
can find by just tracing this down to the x-axis, straight below the point. And
that is 5. So, our point of intersection is 5,19. The x-coordinate here is 5, so
x must equal 5. Let's check this in our original equation. We started off with
the equation 3 x plus 4 equals 19. Let's plug in our x value to see if this
works. On the left-hand side, we'll have 3 times 5 plus 4, which simplifies to
19. The right-hand side has no variables, so there's nothing to change, and we
can just write 19. Sure enough, 19 equals 19. So, we're good. x equals 5 is the
correct answer.